okay this question comes from scratch
didn't get a chance to eat today and i'm
starving
all in caps how do survivalists get by
on like one bug a day we don't actually
the reality of survival situation is you
spend most of your time groveling for
food everybody thinks
you're going to make a bow and arrow out
of a piece of thread and a bobby pin
it ain't going to happen going hungry is
not that big of a deal without water
you're in big trouble
without food you've got a couple of
weeks before you're in real
trouble so when i'm in a survival
situation and i've got no food what ends
up happening to me is i become really
lethargic that's the downside of no food
you lose your energy but you don't die
instantly hey
i'm les stroud and this is survivalist
support
[Music]
all right first question comes from just
mickey and he or she
asks not sure if anyone watched platform
on netflix but wouldn't it be healthier
to eat the maggots instead of the rotten
meat okay so first of all
full disclosure i have not seen platform
on netflix actually i haven't even heard
of it
but i have heard of maggots and i have
heard of rotting meat and i have eaten
both there is protein
in both eating rotten meat is always the
thing that seems repugnant to everybody
in a survival situation
the reality is that you can eat rotting
meat in fact many years ago
most of our cultures all ate rotting
meat of some sort we have it
in many of our different recipes if you
will
different things that we ate we're often
rotting fish
rotting fowl rotting red meat
it goes on and on the maggots are full
of protein and sweetness and sugars
the real answer to this question eat
them both all right next question matt
voorhees
asks real lestrade that's me serious
survival question open to anyone went on
a hike today and saw a baby bear in a
tree
how close was the mom with question mark
exclamation point question mark and
exclamation point so this person's
excited
we immediately left the area okay so an
apex predator is like
great white sharks polar bears african
lions
indian tigers but a secondary predator
is the kind of predator that
may eat you but it's likely going to be
an accidental
occasion so black bears cougars even
grizzly bears
in the case of a black bear and for that
matter in the case of a cougar
get big get scary you can scare them
away what does that mean if you come
upon
a mother and her cubs the majority of
the times
the mother will be taking off like a
shot she'll go and she'll hide somewhere
and the cubs will go up a tree
how close is the mom bottom line you
don't really want to take the chance
because this is the one time
when a black bear is actually very
dangerous a mother and her cubs any
other time i would work really hard to
scare a black bear away
but when it's a mother and her cubs i'm
not going to take any chances
at all so how close was the mother bear
to the cubs
does it really matter it's a mother bear
and she's
big and probably 340 pounds and you're
not
all right this next question comes from
steve steve sundell sundell
i'm watching survivorman right now
survivor man no it's survivorman
one word get it right steve i'm watching
survivorman
right now and i still have a lingering
question for survivalists
why not just always bring
a bic lighter with you you know what
steve i've got the same freaking
question if you're going to go out in
the wilderness take a bic lighter with
you
every single time why not i agree
why not always do it okay this next
question comes with a photograph
from frosty hey les
how do you like my first attempt at
spoon making
it's beautiful frosty it's a thing of
beauty it's a work
of art and i gotta tell you this story
when you take a survival class
the first thing you ever make is not a
shelter
it's not a deadfall or a trap or a snare
it's not a bow and arrow it's a carved
out wooden spoon
that's the first thing we always teach
in survival class is how to carve out a
spoon
then we go on to trap some animals or
gather some wild edibles
and then the spoon comes in handy what
we always want to do when we're teaching
survival
those of us who are survival instructors
is get people comfortable with their
hands
with building things with cutting things
with nature but especially with using
knives it's incredible how often i'll
see people in a survival class
with no knife using skills whatsoever
later when you're trying to carve out
larger objects when you're making
deadfalls and snares and traps and bows
and arrows
you're much more handy with the knife
all right next question comes from arien
buck
at real estate how do you keep the
camera batteries charged
during your excursions i get that
question a lot in fact i get a lot of
questions about my camera gear and
feel technique and i love those
questions because as a filmmaker
i enjoy sharing my creativity and how i
came about it
and one of the biggest issues in filming
survivorman and indeed in filming my
adventures before survivorman
was keeping batteries charged i spent a
year living in the woods and and made a
documentary called snowshoes and salted
and i literally took with me a car
battery
and a solar panel charged the car
battery during the day and at night with
the little adapter
charge my camera batteries and that got
me through a whole year but it's
way different now i can put in a small
pack
on my hip enough battery power
to last me a week easily the batteries
got small
they got long lasting so i just charge
everything up at home
and take a bunch in with me and it's
actually not too heavy anymore
steve schwinghammer it's really hard not
to comment on that
steve schwinghammer how do you prepare
for a trip
do you binge in the morning before to
stay full as long as possible or would
that cause
problems great question i don't get this
question very often so i want to answer
it honestly
i don't prepare at all the reason why i
don't prepare it all is because when i'm
going out to film i want it to be as
real as possible i know i'm going out i
know i'm making a film and i know i'm
eventually going to go home
so that nullifies some of the reality of
being in a survival situation so if i
were to also prepare
by either gorging on food or slimming
down and trying to make my
stomach smaller so it doesn't hurt as
much when i'm in the woods either way
both of those ways in my mind
are cheating because when you get lost
in the woods you don't prepare the night
before thinking i'm gonna be lost
tomorrow
and so i needed to have that reality
there so i didn't prepare at all i just
go in as i go in if i had a big
breakfast that morning great if i didn't
i didn't twofos1 asks les how do you
disinfect your hands in the wild after
handling meat you're about to cook
in this very disinfected society i
struggle because
i believe and agree with science that
points out that we have a lot of
bacteria that is healthy and that we
need
now out in the wilderness there's even
more of that healthy bacteria and even
less of the nasty stuff we're going to
get in the grocery store from a shelf
so i'm a big supporter of getting
outside and getting dirt up your
fingernails
and being part of the bacteria that's in
nature so to answer your question
twofold one i don't
disinfect my hands after handling meat
i'm about to cook in the wilderness
in fact i eat a lot of the wild meat i
might catch or come upon
raw like carpaccio or sushi i don't
disinfect my hands i go with the flow
i believe that it's actually made me
stronger over the years chad harmon asks
how do you keep from inhaling a ton of
smoke when starting fire it killed me
the few times i tried and i'm a smoker
you kind of don't there is one trick
when i'm doing the fire bow
and i'm and i'm blowing into the embers
and all that you breathe
you just turn to the side it's like
or if i'm down and i'm trying to get a
fire going on the ground getting started
again it's like
so otherwise absolutely i've gone
and choked and sucked in so much smoke
and
meanwhile you're trying to get your fire
going so not a good time to stall
so there's not a really great answer to
that question other than turn to the
side and breathe dude
krista wants to know at real estate the
following
is suddenly driving me nuts how does
survivor man brush his teeth
while out there for seven to ten days or
does he oh
you're never going to want to kiss me
because i don't i mean i
i'll use my finger sometimes you can
take roots
like spruce roots and things and kind of
do like a
you know cleaning of your teeth but
mostly you're out in the bush you ain't
cleaning your teeth
and yeah it is kind of gross at trouba
girl
let's start if you truly only had one
single pick at a survival tool
what would you pick no matter what the
terrain easy answer and i get this
question a lot i
would have a way to start a fire uh
oh no no you gotta have a knife no you
need to axe no you starting a fire is
probably the most difficult thing in a
survival situation
i don't want to rub two sticks together
fire is just one of those things that
serves so many purposes that i feel
that the best survival skill is knowing
how to get a fire going so
my number one tool a method to start a
fire preferably a butane torch lighter
style
all right hopefully i'm pronouncing this
correctly eddie minion
at real lestrade thoughts on altoid tin
survival kits
as set and forget items what would you
put in yours
interesting question don't get me going
on survival kits
here's the first way i want to answer
this question was to say if you're going
to have a survival kit
do not buy it off the shelf don't do it
turn away
walk out of the store come back when
you're ready to seek out your own
items for your survival kit pick the
things that are high quality
know that you know how to use them learn
how to use them put your own
kit together that's the answer i will
always give as far as which is the best
survival kit to have it's the one that
you make yourself with items you sourced
that you know how to use because
anything else is just a case of trinkets
you open it up most of it's probably
going to be junk if it's bought off the
shelf
and half the time you won't even know
how to use them so that's my answer
build and keep your own survival kit all
right this looks like a serious question
mr
hemtastic wants to know what would you
say to someone who wants to take a year
or so and walk the great trail
through canada any advice on planning or
anything
i could go on for the next hour on
giving you advice on this one
do it don't hesitate do it don't think
about
making money over that period of time or
the money you have to make before you go
in or what you're coming out to
just do it too many of us do not
embark on an adventure because we're
obsessed with or concerned about our our
at-home lives our regular lives if
you're going out alone or you've got a
partner
i say do it i spent a year living in the
woods and i remember getting a question
one time
how can anyone afford to spend a year
living in the woods
and the crowd went a little silent and i
just took a breath and i just answered
you can't and i got a standing ovation
with that answer
because the truth is you can't put these
roadblocks in front of you before you're
about to embark on a great adventure
just embark on
it prepare for it write things down make
a lot of lists there's my pragmatic
answer for you
write down a lot of lists get it all
focused in
and go for it mike henley asks what
would you say are the top five edible
winter plants
in the tomogame region for those of you
who don't know where tomogame is
tomogamy
is in my opinion the canoeing
mecca of the world there is no place
where you can carry out long distance
river to lake to river canoe trips like
you can in tomogram
ontario canada it is stunning there
and not very many people go there it's
not a a major
national park kind of situation so you
have stunning vistas
amazing canoeing and not very many
people there it's fantastic so
it's a great question to ask but it also
leads me down another road
top five edible winter plants in the
tomography region this is a tricky
answer because as i like to say in a
survival situation
if you're not on a tropical island it's
pretty hard to be vegan
it's pretty hard to be vegetarian it's
almost radically
impossible so you need to be able to in
a winter situation in tomogram
catch game like snowshoe hare which are
easy to catch
just the same to answer your question
mikey certainly cattail
is always a good winter one because you
can if you can get through the snow
through the ice down to the bottom
through the freezing cold water
the the growth for next year is down
there and they can be anything from an
inch to six inches long
and it's a beautiful edible it's kind of
like a cucumber other than that
you're reduced to a lot of wild teas
spruce teas pine tea willow tea birch
tea boy
that's about it it's hard to gather wild
edibles in the winter time
in northern canada but go to tomogram
you'll love it okay with the radically
esoteric and creative
web name of graham he asks i've got a
long trip
in the scottish highlands in winter what
should i pack in my car for an emergency
whoa great question graham
i can't say this enough that you know
when i teach about having survival kits
there's my
personal survival kit there's the group
survival kit if i'm traveling with
people
i'm also teaching survival kits for in
the home
home survival kit but what's often
overlooked and it's so easy
is a car survival kit for emergencies
so really the first thing you need for
your car is you know one of those sort
of bins
plastic bins with a nice tight fitting
lid size wise
oh you know enough that could take 12
bottles of wine or 24 bottles of wine
but that big
and in that you pack everything you
think you'll need some way to start a
fire
way to cook and boil water insulation
material like a sleeping bag or
something like that
it's your car you can set up an
emergency kit for your car
and just leave it and forget that it's
even there and that
afternoon that you decide to take that
shortcut
because it's going to be so cool oh i
wonder what that's going to be like over
there and that's where you get the flat
tire and you notice that your spares
also flat you're going to thank me for
having
a car survival kit so what should you
pack in it
use your own sort of powers of intuition
and ingenuity what do you think you need
if you were stuck with that car on a
remote hill
in the highlands of scotland kathleen
stokes
phillips asks gotta ask you the silliest
question
well actually she's asking it on capital
so gotta ask you the silliest question
where do you find toilet paper to go poo
lol depending on where you are usually
the best toilet paper in the woods
is moss most of the moss you'll find if
not all of it is
not poisonous to the touch leaves are
tricky
you do not want to wipe your butt with
poison oak you do not
want to wipe your butt with poison ivy
you do not
want to wipe your butt with a cactus
plant so find moss
that's toilet paper in fact my favorite
kind of moss which
sadly for the lower 48 you can't really
get but up in the boreal forest
there's a mosque called sphagnum moss
and for years
it was actually used by indigenous
cultures as their diapers as their
toilet paper
it has antiseptic qualities to it it's
my favorite toilet paper it's soft and
it's good
whether it's moist or dry and that's
where i should stop there or it's gonna
become too much information
jalana kia i like that name jolana kia
asks if perfect balance isn't part of
your survivalist skill set
how are you going to make it past your
70s hmm
good point you might not do so well and
that's why
i still to this day and for the sake of
a guy with a back that is beaten up by
by carrying canoes heavy packs and
playing hockey
i still do yoga every single day because
balance
is important something that's overlooked
in a survival situation is
one of the key components of whether or
not you will survive something
is actually your fitness level and so
even for
hardcore wilderness survival my yoga
helps me a lot
when i gotta scale that rocky area and
climb through that
go through that swamp balance is really
important so how are you gonna make it
past your 70s
without balance with difficulty everyone
thank you so much for the questions
obviously some of them were silly and
some of them were serious
and i like approaching survival that way
anyway because the thing is you gotta
laugh
if you're in a survival situation
remember there is only one thing you
want to do
go home you don't want to get to the
other end of a survival situation and go
oh i wish i'd made a better a-frame
shelter man i wish i'd tend to hide
you want to go home in a survival
situation so humor
is important to keep your spirits alive
i'm really grateful for these questions
they've been great i'm les stroud and
this has been survival support